[Musique]
cool associatif est né c'est un nouveau
service
qui est née du constat simple que les
associations sabre et c'est un clip
partout dans les services de la ville
auprès des services de la ville pour
tout un tas de raisons différentes
offre une palette de services qui vont
de renseignements par rapport à leur
statut sur les réglementations pour
mettre à disposition dans
nouvel espace de vie associative tout
abouti ils sont des salles de réunion et
i think i media
sans les présidents et les bureaux
d'associations sans tous ceux qui font
un boulot vraiment merveilleux dans
cette ville et qui viennent tous les
jours nous solliciter pour tel local
telles actions j'aurais vraiment vouloir
réserver aussi à tous un tonnerre
[Applaudissements]
dans toute l'ue ont assez peu de temps
recenser toutes une série de besoins
manifestés par les parents notamment
proposé je prends un micro en tout cas
c'est ce que j'ai déjà eu comme retour
une programmation intéressante qu'il
s'agisse des groupes de paroles de
moments conviviaux entre parents d'
ateliers parents-enfants très important
de temps de réflexion avec des
professionnels sur l'autorité parentale
ou la scolarité donc remercie évidemment
les parents je l' ai parlé avec un
certain nombre d'entre eux
l'espace des parents ces initiatives la
mairie de sainte geneviève des bois et
plus particulièrement en fait c'est une
initiative du groupe de travail
du projet éducatif de territoires ddt
qui ont voulu mettre en place un espace
dédié aux parents et qui donc a pour
objectif de d'être un lieu de rencontre
et de partage de mettre en place des
moments conviviaux destine aux parents
pour qu'ils puissent partager leurs
compétences et puis aussi de mettre en
place des temps d'animation des
animations mutinés exclusivement aux
parents mais aussi des ateliers par
enfant
on peut informer les parents
et ils peuvent aussi se documenter sur
tous les toutes les problématiques que
peuvent rencontrer tous les parents du
territoire
[Musique]